i
[Música]
ah
en argentina viven entre 100.000 y
150.000 descendientes de armenios de
acuerdo con cifras de la propia
comunidad es la más grande colectividad
armenia de américa latina' cientos de
ellos se movilizaron días atrás en la
ciudad de buenos aires para pedir un
cese del fuego en nagorno karabaj o
artsaj como se denomina la región en
armenio los enfrentamientos comenzaron
el 27 de septiembre pasado y ya dejaron
cientos de muertos son parte de un
conflicto de décadas nagorno karabaj es
un territorio que se encuentra en el
interior de azerbaiyán en el cáucaso
pero está disputado por la vecina
armenia y habitado principalmente por
armenios quedó unilateralmente separado
de azerbaiyán a comienzos de la década
de los 90 tras una guerra que dejó
decenas de miles de muertos y alrededor
de un millón de desplazados pero la
disputa nunca se resolvió y ambos países
siguen reclamando como propio el
territorio
[Música]
me encuentro en la ciudad de glendale
que es un suburbio de la ciudad de los
ángeles
aquí en glendale se encuentra la mayor
cantidad de ciudadanos armenios que
viven fuera de su país estos ciudadanos
se han manifestado prácticamente a
diario
cerrando autopistas haciendo
manifestaciones dirigiéndose a la
alcaldía de glendale el alcalde es
obviamente de origen armenio también han
hablado con la alcaldía de la ciudad de
los ángeles para pedir ayuda y hacer
conocer lo que está sucediendo en su
país en esta guerra que están viviendo
con azerbaiyán culpan los manifestantes
al gobierno turco de lo que está pasando
muchos han hecho diferentes tipos de
eventos para recaudar fondos para enviar
dinero a su país e incluso se dice que
muchos armenios que viven o vivían aquí
en glendale han regresado a su país para
apoyarlo durante este conflicto que
están viviendo con uno de sus vecinos
[Música]
la comunidad armenia de cataluña también
se moviliza aquí desde hace semanas para
pedir a la comunidad internacional una
mediación en el conflicto del territorio
de nagorno karabaj
así pues hace pocos días cortaron la
autopista que une españa con francia en
la frontera catalana durante más de
cuatro horas según un portavoz de esta
comunidad están dispuestos a llevar a
cabo más cortes de este tipo hasta que
el gobierno español arce la voz quieren
que pedro sanz es el jefe del gobierno
español
el primero pida a turquía no
involucrarse en este conflicto y segundo
que se suspenda las ventas de armas a
turquía pero de momento pero sánchez
dice que apuesta más por el diálogo
entre ambas partes mientras que aquí el
parlamento catalán aprobó hace pocos
días gracias a los votos de los partidos
independentistas y los partidos de la
izquierda una resolución que
éxito textualmente condena los ataques
de azerbayán contra la población civil
[Música]